[music plays throughout]
The Wyss Institute
has developed an innovative approach
to fighting cancer.
This approach was developed
in collaboration with biologists,
clinicians, and researchers
at the Dana-Farber
Cancer Institute
in Harvard School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences.
Cancer is able to grow
because tumors are made
of the patient's own cells
which the immune system
does not recognize as a threat.
The Wyss cancer vaccine technology
reprogrammed the immune system
to reject these tumor cells.
The vaccine
is a spongy porous matrix,
approximately the size
of a standard aspirin tablet,
and is implanted directly under the skin
near a lymph node.
The vaccine is designed
to quickly release the protein
granulocyte-macrophage
colony-stimulating factor
into the surrounding tissue,
which attracts dendritic cells –
a specific type of immune cell –
into the vaccine.
These immune cells
are then re-programmed
with fragments
of the tumor cells,
along with a signal
mimicking an infection.
These activated immune cells
then hone to the nearest lymph node,
where they train other cells
of the immune system
to recognize the tumor cells
as something dangerous
that should be destroyed.
Specifically in the lymph node,
the activated dendritic cells
present tumor cell fragments
to certain T-cells of the immune system.
These trained T-cells
then proliferate.
These cytotoxic T-cells
circulate throughout the body
looking for any
of these same tumor cells
to attack and destroy.
The vaccination
not only could destroy tumor cells,
but it could also create
immune memory,
which could provide
a long-term protection
against tumor reoccurence.
The vaccine safely degrades over time
and is then excreted by the body.
With this new technology,
we can potentially revolutionize
cancer care.
[music ends]